Many of our viewers have asked
us a very serious question.
What if we made a big pile of bottoms
and exploded every nuclear weapon in the
world all at once?
Strangely enough,
we couldn't find a good source to answer
this question to our satisfaction.
So we gathered together a few scientists
to calculate what would happen and find
an answer to this extremely important
scientific problem once and for all.
Currently there are 15,000
nuclear weapons on earth.
The U S and Russia both have around 7,000
well, France, China, the UK, Pakistan,
India, Israel, and North Korea
earn around 1000 between them.
But how much destructive power is this?
Really?
Let's try to put these
numbers into perspective.
On Earth,
there are about 4,500 cities or urban
areas with at least 100,000 inhabitants.
Some are bigger than others,
so we'll assume that on average,
we need three nuclear bombs to
completely wipe out one city.
This means we could destroy every single
city of Atlantis Earth without nuclear.
Our arsenal killing more
than 3 billion people,
roughly half of humanity in an instant,
and we'd still have 1,500
nuclear weapons left.
Now that's what an expert
would call overkill.
So we can say with confidence that we
have a lot of nuclear weapons and they can
do a lot of damage.
But what if we make a huge pilot level
15,000 bombs and pull the trigger?
Let's drop our nuclear pile in the middle
of the Amazon rain forest just to show
nature whose boss our warheads piled
haphazardly fits into a small warehouse.
A typical us warhead has the
power of 200,000 tons of TNT.
So 15,000 warheads would be the equivalent
of 3 billion tons of TNT for scale.
This is enough to rebuild the whole island
of Manhattan with every building and
skyscraper using stacks of TNT.
The closest thing we can compare to
the energy gathered here is a volcano.
One of the deadliest volcanic eruptions
in recorded history took place in 1883
on the island of Krakatoa.
Eruption was so powerful that 70% of the
island and the surrounding archipelago
was destroyed.
Killing tens of thousands of people.
It's affects were felt around the
world for days after the event.
Our nuclear pile contains 15 times the
energy of the Krakatoa volcanic eruption.
So let's find me.
Push the button three to one in a second.
A fireball,
50 kilometers across it
vaporizes everything in its
way and creates a blast wave
that flattens 3000 square
kilometers of forest.
Every living thing within 250
kilometers will start to burden.
The explosion will be heard literally
around the world as the pressure wave
circles the earth tens of
times over the next few weeks,
millions of tons of incinerated material
art catapulted into the atmosphere.
The mushroom cloud reaches the
outer reaches of the stratosphere,
pushing up against space itself.
After things have calmed down,
a small crater about 10 kilometers across
his left in the center of the worst
wildfires the planets has
seen in millennia spreading
throughout South America,
burning down forests and cities alike,
and now the unpleasant part begins
extremely radioactive material will kill
living things very quickly and a
large area, several kilometers around.
The crater is now uninhabitable,
as is everywhere.
For hundreds of kilometers downwind.
Much of the fallout is carrot high into
the atmosphere by the mushroom cloud and
carried around the planet.
The amount of radioactive material
in the environment doubles worldwide,
which still isn't civilization ending,
but we may see more cancer for a while.
A portion of the particles will flow to
the edge of space for years and cause a
nuclear winter that could lower global
temperatures by a few degrees for a few
years.
This explosion was pretty bad.
If you're in South America
and especially Brazil,
the Amazon rain forest is pretty
much history, which is not great,
but human life will go on.
Okay,
but what if we expose
more nuclear weapons?
Let's suppose humanity decided to mine
every bit of uranium on earth and build
as many nuclear bombs as possible.
At current usage,
it's estimated that there are around 35
million tons of uranium in Earth's crust,
enough to power human civilization for
over 2000 years or to build millions of
new peer warheads.
For the sake of argument.
Let's say we create a pile with the
yield of 10 billion Hiroshima bombs,
which makes up a cube three kilometers
high that contains at roughly the energy
of the asteroid impacts that ended the
age of the dinosaurs 65 million years ago,
except it's also nuclear three two one.
How pile explodes in a fireball
stretching so high into the sky that it's
visible from half of South America
with so much power that the ground just
splashes like water forming a crater 100
kilometers across bedrock on the scale
of Horn mountain ranges is
vaporized in an instance,
while thousands of tons of material is
catapulted away with such speed that it's
injected into space,
some leaves out forever.
While most fair comes raining down as
hot burning debris that heats up the
atmosphere to oven lake temperatures,
killing most big animals and causing
firestorms all over the world.
The Earth's crust rings like a
bell struck by global earthquakes.
It stronger than anything in recorded
history decimating cities around the world
while hurricane force winds,
plaza,
every single tree and South America
and wildfires consume the continents.
The abundance of hydrocarbons in the
Amazon burn to form ash are cast into the
atmosphere dotting the sky and keeping
sunlight from reaching the surface,
dropping temperatures to
near freezing worldwide.
The ensuing global winter may last for
decades and results in the extinction of
every large animal species
Schumer is included.
We could also mention that every
corner of the planet is covered with a
radioactive fallout, but at this point
it doesn't matter that much anymore.
This is humanities extinction event.
The astronauts aboard the International
Space Station get to enjoy a great view
for a while,
but it's not unlikely that the spray of
rocks blast into always will destroy the
station.
Those lucky enough to be in bunkers
or in submarines deep below the ocean
surface may survive the longest before
they exhaust their food supplies and have
to venture out for mall.
They'll find the world a charred,
freezing radioactive wasteland.
The planet itself doesn't care at all.
After just a few million years,
the wounds of the explosions
have healed and life is thriving,
arguably even more so than
when humans are around.
If intelligent life emerges again,
it might be able to work out what
happened when they studied geology.
They'll find a bizarre and very thin
layer of rock covering the entire world,
enriched in radioactive elements like
uranium and the other nasty things it
decays who mixed with rare earth
metals and plastics that humans used.
They would probably be very,
very confused.
Videos like this one take well over
1200 hours to finish. Over the years,
we put more and more effort into research,
conversations with experts,
illustration and animation, sound designer
and fact checking. For this video,
we put a lot of extra work
into our sources document.
You can read how we got to
the information in the video.
What are experts thought about is
where they disagreed with each other.
We can take the time to do this
because of you, our viewers,
because you watch and share our videos
by our posters and supporters on picture
on.com if you liked what we're doing,
please consider becoming a patron or
get one of the nice things we made with
love.
Thank you for watching.